Dr. Karen Bell is the chair of
the Certification Commission for Health Information Technology,
CCHIT, which is a not for profit HIT certification body with an educational mission.
In a June 2013 post on the Health Affairs blog,
Dr. Bell said that models such as
a ACOs must successfully implement seven business processes,
all of which rely heavily on the proper use of Health Informatics.
The seven processes are: care coordination, cohort management,
patient relationship management, clinician engagement,
financial management, reporting, and knowledge management.
To support this, she lists four primary requirements of an ACO HIT infrastructure.
The first demands the ability to share health information between and
among various internal and external providers,
patients, and their designated caregivers.
Second, there needs to be data integration from clinical,
administrative, financial and patient derived sources.
The third requires attention to HIT functions that support patient safety.
The fourth requires strong privacy and security protections.
Most health care organizations have a lot of work to do in order to achieve all of this.
Earlier in her post,
Dr. Bell says that quote,
the promise of Accountable Care is tempered by a dearth of
experience with care process redesign and culture change,
and of knowledge about the health information technology infrastructure
necessary to optimally support healthcare transformation, end quote.
To summarize, the need for health IT to support new care and payment models is clear,
but we still have a long way to go to develop and properly use those systems.
Next we turn to some of the key challenges to doing that.